[Musique]
abbas à la formidable tu vas t'en la wii
dis donc à chamonix
vous pourriez un petit peu fait de lait
le pain à pondre eu des bonnes heures
avec salière c'est là nous avons dormi
tranquillement on s'était déjà passé
l'après midi en plein sur la pierre de
porte bien très bien ça aulas tout ça
c'est bon oui aux petits dans t il
revenir ici un plus de 40 ans bientôt 50
ans en arrière ici et avoir cette chance
de pouvoir survoler en quelques minutes
tout ce qui a été enfin un peu ma vie
quoi et surtout les droits qui en ont
pris hier donc où cette nuit ça a été
très sérieux ces blocs de rochers qui
sont tournées qui ont pulvérisé le bas
de la face mais d'en haut ça aussi bien
vraisemblablement modifier complètement
toutes les voies existantes
c'est quand même très inquiétant de voir
cette montagne partir en pans entiers
par millier de mètres
c'est bien ça vous mine et hilton ça
s'est déjà produit au moins deux ou
trois fois peut-être pas avec cette
importance mais c'est certain c'est
impressionnant
[Musique]
homme d'action et d'anticipation guide
oman yonne fut l'un des meilleurs
alpinistes français des années de
l'après-guerre
c'est un artiste à 20 ans pour assouvir
sa passion de la sculpture
il rentre à l'école des beaux-arts aux
côtés de ceux qui vont devenir et grands
de l'art contemporain
albert féraud et césar magnol l'athlète
formés sur les rochers de fontainebleau
réussite en 1952 avec lucien bardini la
première ascension de la fameuse face
ouest des drus il part alors à la
conquête et à la découverte des plus
beaux sommets de la terre de l'attak
l'agonie à l'himalaya le fitzroy le
makalu la tour de mu style autodidacte
dévoreur de vie toujours animé par cette
volonté de faire partager son
enthousiasme
il participe ensuite à la création de
l'ucp à l'union des centres de plein air
qui dirige pendant plus de 20 ans depuis
un demi-siècle kidman yonne que toi tous
les grands noms de l'alpinisme on se
connaissait pratiquement tout ça c'était
le petit village en bas à chamonix
faisait plaisir retrouver facilement un
compagnon pour rire de grandes courses à
partir avec la shn altérait ou duré
qu'un an ou du gîte ou ou le roux les
suisse vaucher les hôtes lambert bon
ceux qui commençaient à se pointer vers
l'himalaya qui revenait qu'à raconter
leur histoire et qui donnait des envies
mais c'était un nombre limité c'était
hors pas une secte mais presque un
charlie était à nous un peu
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
magnol réside une partie de l'année à
saint raphaël à 80 ans conserve le corps
et l'esprit tendue vers l'action c'est
un bâtisseur de la catégorie de ceux qui
trotte bien et sort pour laisser de
solides fondations toujours guidé par
son instinct la piste revient à son
premier amour le travail de la matière
comme terrain d'expression et il
poursuit la voie qu'il s'est tracée
[Musique]
la forme se dessine au fur à mesure
plutôt rajoute l'étendant lève dans
ajoute un anglais il va une forme moins
satisfaisante et les secrets de
fabrication
khamis commandait
ici c'est mon atelier a en réalité j'ai
eu la chance de pouvoir réaliser un peu
ce rêve il a deux ans rappelle que si je
voulais faire quelque chose de sérieux
il nous fallait un endroit équipe est
assez important pour elle parce que la
sculpture c'est du domaine et je peux y
faire un peu c'est ma retraite quoi ces
mots sont de faire parvenir on était ici
ce sont des grès de fontainebleau que
j'ai taillé en allant jusqu'à la partie
métamorphosé cristalline de façon à
faire apparaître les former en enlevant
le créer de surface qui était qui
partait en sable et j'ai commencé à
faire des formes
j'ai suivi un petit peu beaucoup moins
d'instinct bon encore un beau billet à
tcc ma femme qui a voulu me faire
plaisir qu'il dame isabeau et ça a c'est
la première chose que j'ai faite quand
j'ai commencé recommencer à sculpter ans
je me suis un peu lancé j'ai attrapé un
vieux morceau balcon il y avait un bout
de ferraille qui dépassait g37
agrémenter et à lui donner une forme
très allégorique d'être femme qui rêve
gravats des choses que l'on imagine
aisément
et puis bon ben c'est en cours je
l'abordé avait deux ans mais je leur
prendre un jour tu pas de doute là c'est
mon matériel de montagne m'est très
utile aujourd'hui en sculpture des
humains décor de montagnes tous à
utiliser pour bricoler travailler je
pensais fiche tout ça à la poubelle puis
finalement ça mais extrêmement utile
corde
bousquetains des pythons tout juste le
jus barça pour bloquer mes cordes
alors on a un objet décoratif que l'on
peut ménager
si on aime ça on peut le faire soit en
bas relief soit en ronde bosse comme on
veut moi j'aime ça j'aime les formes les
femmes pour les ford
c'est vrai je le vis une espèce de fait
des types de faim il ya un fait c'est
étonnant c'est l'histoire d'une fille
sera il va évidemment dit bouleversé ma
vie parce que d'une part je me suis mis
à faire de l'alpinisme de façon poussée
définitive la totalité de ma vie était
consacré à ça mais surtout parce qu'elle
m'a fait accéder à un monde que je ne
connaissais pas le monde des médias la
bande des relations importantes des gens
côtoyaient ambassadeur on a été chez
personnes ont été reçues en fait c'est
nouveau pour moi j'ouvre il faudrait il
ya des des yeux comme des on est un peu
commander sur un tapis volant devient
quelque chose
un personnage on change de dimension on
accède à léon reconnaissance des autres
qui est assez régulière alors ça change
la vie
[Musique]
il sera c'est un peu moi qui étais
cherchait en effet relégué telle
solution
j écoute en équipe complète mais
j'avais une vieille tradition avant tout
j'ai mis au monde qui était pour lui un
billet de bateau pour aller à bonal suis
parti en argentine sens très bien savoir
si je resterai en argentine ou suivre
mais c'est sympa je découvrais noms
d'oiseaux formidable j'avais vraiment
envie de faire cette montagne aux
quelque chose je désirais d'accidents
très graves puisque là je pense nous il
a trouvé la mort il était en marche
d'approché avec terreur exploration en
traversant torrent il a perdu
l'équilibré menée par sa charge
impossible de peuvent agir en possible
de venir et il a été noyée sous les yeux
de leurs alter à l'heure
[Musique]
tout de suite on en a pris comme on dit
le plaqueur mois mettant sur sa robe et
un bonnet temps mauvais temps
ça a été notre fête intérêt à moins que
la gamine tente vitrine des tentes de
l'anapurna la pauvre elle a duré à peu
près un quart d'heure s'est fait
complètement mettre en pièces par le
vent n'a creusé chacun deux trous dans
la masse de neige l'a fait une grotte
par la suite on a installé des tentes à
l'intérieur de grandes campagnes et dans
les rues mais dans les glaciers dans les
neiges
semaine à darwin a failli on a fait
rater j'avais plus plus un seul pit
enterrait retrouver lui au fond une
espèce de petite lame tout bête ce qu'on
appelle un as de coeur qui là que j'ai
pu enfoncer de 2 cm dans le rocher pour
de l'arrivée de cet été tout plan alors
là je dois dire que on était le fils
reuil a été réalisée en février 1952
[Musique]
le sable de fontainebleau une
utilisation dans une espèce d'anguille
plâtre et de chaux
c'est la formule je profite de
l'économie vient parfaitement parce
qu'il me donne 10 cultures qui sont
assez ferme est assez douces en surface
même si elles ne sont pas à son mat on
peut presque les caresser c'est tout à
fait différent de ce qu'on a l'habitude
et puis surtout ça se travaille très
bien passé très bien mais on a amélioré
limitée travail
la création dada sculpteur c'est la
forme c'est l'objet qui provoque une
émotion un sentiment c'est l'utilisation
des vides et des pleins comme on utilise
à un son en musique on est sensibles où
on n'est pas sensible à cette modulation
de cette manière de faire ne permet à
moi prendre deux ans de faire 30 pièces
si j'avais dû travailler de façon
traditionnelle comme au travail et dans
le temps 4 pour analyser tous ces
acteurs à perdre
[Musique]
quand on grimpe au comptant ont fait de
la montagne on touche là pierre et on a
sensibilité on a quelque chose qui vient
de se toucher de la montagne et dans la
sculpture c'est c'est peut-être là le
vrai rapport qui lie à entre la
sculpture et la montagne c'est que s'est
matérialisé s'est concrétisée c'est
quelque chose de donc que l'on que l'on
peut saisir quelle que l'on peut
manipuler et que l'on peut toucher enfin
que l'on sent
[Musique]
j'étais décidé à faire une exposition
est tout de suite le comité d'himalaya
m'a sollicité pour préparer la très
grande expédition qui devait aller à
l'everest
il a fallu qu'on attend notre tour iris
portillon il y avait les suisses et il y
avait des anglais le népal le délivrer
qu'un ticket à la fois les anglais ont
eu des ponts et panneaux gagné 53 ont
été la décision française ou macalou
préparer les vraies celles où le makalu
[Musique]
ça a été l'ex pdis ion idéal la féra
temps magnifique toujours démonter il
n'y a pas eu de pépins
tout le monde est monté au sommet on a
fait monter guys and serdar
symboliquement pour que les sherpas soit
soucier monsieur que l'on va dire l'a28
d'hab je suis je passais par là je vais
raconter ça terrible celle de la face
aux abonnés qui ont coûté dire quand la
voix de bonatti
il ya un abri dont elle n'a pas été
touchée elle est juste c'est juste es tu
vois des plaques gigantesque comme ils
disent un morceau d'histoire est parti
dans les éboulis et se met en porte ça
se casse la figure
d'ailleurs les gens s'attendent à ce que
ça continue tombé de haut q votre un peu
de ce que tu as ton ces derniers temps
regarde-moi 16
samedi midi oui mesdemoiselles regarde
le mouvement s'est fait qu'ils
assassinent moi je nettoie j'aime
beaucoup
sa vie non oui ça c'est traître tu sais
pourquoi tu aimes ça parce que j'ai un
côté plus décoratif peut-être ça me fait
un peu sourire toujours dirhams le
carbone veut jouir regarde ça le soudan
me nomme c'est autre chose et je crois
aussi que lui a aussi dit à l'ats par la
composition
c'est presque une histoire d'école
contre avec righi d'eau ont passé
l'admission à l'école des beaux-arts
ensemble c'était pendant la guerre oui
c'était un grand champion déjà joué au
water-polo le grand séducteur
didot puis c'est vrai que c'est une
extraordinaire là il nous secouer et oui
j'étais sportif et se découvre l eau le
monde clastiques quad est ce que c'était
que il avait quand même été je crois
reçu promu enfin et c'est un hasard et
que l'occident
il est touché tout les taxis dans des
rôles dont on parlait de bagnone bonatti
tout ça j'étais l'himalaya le yéti je
dois dire que je suis toujours en
relation épistolaire avec lui j'adresse
un post régionales si le damier
il apparaît dans retire à damier t se
posent aux usagers n'ont donc au côté un
peu livrés toujours que qui s'exprime
parfaitement dans ces pilotes ont dit
non le truc
audii johnny dont il est toujours doté
d'un matériel gigantesque puissant des
compresseurs des presses c'est un peu
étonnant de d'imaginer que pour faire
une chose subtiles comme la sculpture
ils se servent de dodo moyens mécaniques
aussi puissant aussi extraordinaire on
est chez vulcain quoi on est passé à
paulhan déchets vulcain et là où la
salle albert féraud pour tout dire c'est
un grand de la sculpture française est à
sculpture international indiscutablement
ce ne peut pas simplement cantonné ma
vie dans toute cette période
en tranchant ce qu'il put your penis mme
la découverte des piles et des gens et a
été pour moi peut-être beaucoup plus
fondamentale comme une étude arrivée au
sommet du mât canine denis style c'est
ça le retour de notre expédition que
nous avons la fierté à la grande fête
annuelle de tanis près de nam chez
bayard dans la balle et de soin nos
chronos c'est la vallée du cher pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
regarde ça c'est ma baraque là cette
vieille ferme que j'ai acheté en 74 je
ferai noms de victimes comme que 200 en
un peu plus de 580 à secteur connaît
bien devenir la culture des choses un
non mais c'est vrai il faut les
préserver
quel plaisir de voir un peu inattendue
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mélangeant tous et personne n'est pas
trop long mais je comprends
rodari je pense faire partie d'un groupe
de machin tout ça m'intéresse a beau les
gens tu m'agresses individuellement
tabarly à temps j'ai pu dire des choses
pareilles 20 ans joe barresi ce récit
d'une aventure signe d'un alpiniste
presque disparu marquée de quelques
camps de dans sa finalité
mais bientôt tellement vie alors par
sabine et ici ça c'est adrien de gori
chocolatier puisserguier et
d'innovation' joe barresi a quand même
parcours particulier et qualité très
spécial illégitime à douchy les guides
de montagne des moniteurs de ski sur les
vendettas des leçons du cpa farhat à
dire guy doré m'en bats les c
je n'ai jamais eu aucun problème par
contre accepté un directeur de 36 parce
que dès le première année j'ai pas eu
peur je me suis posé que d'un centre
huit mois parce que c'était ma
personnalité
je me suis senti bien dans j'ai retrouvé
une espèce de second famille j'espère ça
a été ma famille de la montagne et du
ski
[Musique]
pourquoi je fais ça a finalement je me
pose toujours ailleurs mais en fait
c'est pour exister c'est pour exister
mais existait vraiment sur un sujet
peut-être un challenge quelque chose de
nouveau
eux qui me donne un motif de de faire la
montagne c'était ça la natation c'était
ça et l'ucp ah c'était ça fait une
impression bizarre j'ai l'impression
bizarre j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'est d'autres personnes c'est pas moi
ce sont d'autres faits et ils ont fait
tout ça et parce que je ne veux pas me
retourner en fait même si je suis j'y
suis obligé
je veux aller de l'avant ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de faire quelque chose
de nouveau mais c'était c'est de
continuer à faire à faire exister
voilà
[Musique]